[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
en cet été 1793 il n'avait pas encore 16
ans il était garde au puy du fou
il s'appelait jacques mobilier les 500
participants du spectacle ce soir là
vendée entendent bien le 16 juin
prochain prouver que la qualité n'est
pas que parisienne jean piat françois
chaumette marie dubois entend contrer
les textes et alexandre lagoya composer
un thème
voilà pour paris le reste la vendée s'en
charge et le reste trouvera que le
bénévolat n'est pas mort comme on le dit
trop souvent 500 participants 250
figurants plus de vingt cavaliers des
artificiers et cetera et cetera tous de
la région et chacune des 13 communes
participantes on verra une trentaine
d'acteurs il revenait à la maison
changer de chemise
son visage s'assombrit ce soir la vendée
est un spectacle que le conseil général
a rendu possible en rachetant au mois
d'octobre le château du puy du fou
il s'agissait pour lui pour les
habitants de la région de restaurer ce
château renaissance un des seuls en
france à être construits en granit et
installés par la suite un musée régional
rejeté revers du fossé comme des fleurs
faucher qu'il y ait ici un site
remarquable
il y à une scène naturelle est
extraordinaire il y a à la fois le
château la terrasse les temps les temps
de 5 hectares une prairie un promontoire
dans cette prairie où nous pourrons
placer les gens vraiment une semaine
extraordinaire à ce scénario évoque
l'histoire de la vendée à travers le
témoignage que peut nous apporter le
château du puy du fou qui a vécu
lui-même tous les grands événements
heureux et malheureux de l'histoire des
bocages et plus généralement de
l'histoire de la vendée
un jour il s'est mis à pleurer il
enrageait courant là bas dans la prairie
éclaboussé de sang est debout face au
château en flammes
sa lèvre inférieure trembler sur ses
dents serrées
lui non plus n'avait rien pu faire les
colonnes infernales de turreau était
passé pour ce soir là vendée on attend
déjà 25000 spectateurs première le 16
juin 1978
[Musique]
est-ce que vous connaissiez un peu
l'histoire du château avant de voir les
spectacles va pourtant de la région bah
oui mais non personne m'avait raconté
l'histoire semble intéressé à wimereux
trou qu'est ce qui vous a plu surtout
surtout les les lumières l'apa le décor
beaucoup de décors l'histoire aussi
parce qu'on connaît pas l'histoire de
notre pays
est ce que ça a changé la vie de la
commune ce spectacle je pense que oui
parce que vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
ne jouent qu'une part ne savait pas trop
comment comment orienter certains noisy
certaines et certains week-ends par
exemple quand on a appris qu'il y avait
ce passé un spectacle au puy du fou vous
ai déjà conduit en bas ça c'est chouette
alors on va pouvoir y participer moi la
première j'avoue que ce qui me concerne
j'ai été tout de suite
subjugué dans cette rue cler m'a demandé
tout de suite dit oui puis par free dès
le mois de mai lorsque philippe de
villiers un jeune énarque et prix de la
vendée et les villageois de 11 communes
ont commencé ensemble les préparatifs de
cette résurrection
le château du puy du fou a perdu sa
tranquillité ont sommeillé leur
tranquillité les 12 cents participants
ont perdu en même temps au nom de ce
plaisir bien particulier qui annonce le
spectacle le soir lorsque tout
s'assombrit puis six lignes il faut voir
dans quelles conditions on a eu les
répétitions cet hiver les répétitions
qui ont commencé à partir du 1er mai on
a toujours travaillé dans la boue sous
la pluie
et je pense à tous ces figurants qui
venait de faire leur journée de travail
philippe de villiers nous disait que
leur disait quelquefois on va arrêter
mais il voulait continuer à faire leur
répétition même sous la pluie dans les
villages y avait une une chaude amitié
tout le monde ça mais bien on rigole un
bon coup on se retrouvait à toutes les
répétitions et puis alors chacun dise on
le croyait pas un petit artiste devant
un succès pareil quand on pense que
toutes les laisser en jeu nous donne
cinq à six mille spectateurs
c'est plein à craquer ça marche trop
bien puisque les spectateurs ne sont pas
très contents pour une partie d'entre
eux en tout cas puisque nous ne pouvons
pas leur refuser l'accès au spectacle
étant donné qu'il n'y a que 19 séances
et dans le côté nous ne pouvons pas leur
promettre à tous du moins d'être assis
confortablement puisque la moitié des
spectateurs chaque séance
la moitié des 6000 spectateurs puisque
c'est à peu près la moyenne que nous
faisons sont assis sur l'herbe dans les
conditions qui ne leur permettent pas de
bien voir le spectacle et certains
d'entre eux sont pleines
nous nous en excusons mais ce n'est pas
possible nous sommes débordés par
rapport à tout ce que nous pouvions
espérer départ pour début on savait pas
dans quelle dans quel ar on se on se
mettait évidemment on pensait que
c'était
ils petite affaire alors que maintenant
certainement pris l'important c'est
évidemment on est très heureux du succès
de cette entreprise mais enfin encore
que le mot entreprise est mal choisi ils
ont qu on est débordé est-ce que vous
avez vous ce sentiment un moment dont on
parlait tout à l'heure un petit
sentiment de ras-le-bol
oui oui parce que vraiment on était
submergé il nous demandait pas mal de
choses à faire mais toujours on le
faisait sans dégoût on avait vraiment
envie de le faire via c'était la fatigue
et puis tout à coup bon alors les
spectacles commandes c'est puis le
public vient vous avez été un peu un peu
surpris du succès oui et c'est ces
succès qui nous a aidés à continuer
tout de suite on a vu que c'était bon
tout le monde a senti qu'il fallait
continuer et c'est ça qui a fait marcher
tous ceux qui travaillent bénévolement
dans l'ombre parce que il ya les
figurants mais il ya sûrement autant de
personnes qui travaillent nombre
phénomène nouveau dans un spectacle
c'est ce qui a permis de réunir des gens
de communes différentes qui non
seulement ne se parlent pas mais qui
parfois était en état de d'hostilité les
uns avec les autres puisqu'il y avait un
esprit de un esprit de clocher assez
extraordinaire entre les communes
environnantes
alors que maintenant toutes ces communes
et tous ces gens vont main dans la main
et se retrouvent tous les vendredis et
samedis soir pour la grande fête au puy
du fou
il
[Musique]
ou accident l'explosion d'une tonne
d'artifice utilisés pour le spectacle du
puy du fou a créé une certaine émotion
l'autre nuit
une enquête est en cours l'hypothèse
d'un acte de malveillance n'est pas
exclu dix minutes avant l'explosion le
gardien de nuit avait effectué sa ronde
alors je suis partie environ à 1h30 du
matin pour effectuer une ronde
je me doute le secteur quoi et je suis
arrivé ici je me mets à peu près un
quart d'heure personnes à rome
bon je suis arrivé ici à la poudrière
jeu j'ai stationné puis descendre de ma
voiture j'ai fait le tour avec ma pile
en donnant de les éclairages colonnes
sur ce truc j'ai vu aucun indice qui
pouvaient
[Musique]
lundi matin à 1h50
une violente explosion a détruit une
tonne d'artifice utilisés pour les
nombreuses scènes du spectacle du puy du
fou en vendée des murs en béton
disloquées des blocs de plus d'une
centaine de kilos projeté à 30 50 voire
à 100 mètres de là il y avait dans ce
bâtiment dont il ne reste plus rien
hormis les fondations 30 millions de
centimes
accident ou acte de vandalisme l'anc est
immédiatement ouverte se poursuit les
expertises sont actuellement en pleine
recherche si je puis dire
les services compétents à la fois
départementaux les spécialistes nantais
est aujourd'hui même nous attendons un
spécialiste parisien qui connaissent
bien sûr très bien la question sont en
train d'examiner le terrain pour
retrouver certains indices qui
pourraient expliquer le phénomène qui
s'est passé donc lundi soir je vous
rappelle que lors de mon arrivée j'étais
absolument stupéfait de voir l'ampleur
des dégâts et de retrouver sur tout ce
bois complètement en feu et spectacles à
venir
vont-ils être supprimés a absolument pas
les spectacles à venir à commencer par
celui de vendredi soir se jouera comme à
l'habitude et avec des artifices nos
fournisseurs à l'occasion au fait des
miracles et arriveront à temps pour que
le spectacle se joue de la façon la plus
habituelle plus habituel qui soit madame
monsieur bonsoir 4 millions de francs ça
n'est pas rien c'est la somme que le
fisc réclame après un redressement à
l'association du puy du fou
fondée par philippe de villiers vous le
savez qui organise chaque année le
spectacle son et lumière aux herbiers en
vendée le président de l'association
jean marie de la s insurge il y voit là
une liaison avec les récentes
déclarations du député philippe de
villiers sur les affaires de fausses
factures sur ce sujet les responsables
de l'association donnait une conférence
de presse aujourd'hui présents pour fr3
marie-christine duper et max syrie près
de 4 millions c'est la somme rondelette
que réclamait l'administration fiscale à
l'association du puy du fou
deux millions sept de redressement pour
l'exercice 87 88 et sans doute un
million pour celui de 86 contrôlé entre
le 18 mai et le 13 octobre 89 la
notification n'est parvenue aux épaisses
que le doubs
de ce mois là surprise celle
d'aujourd'hui sa place à l'indignation
nous demande de payer un impôt sur les
bénéfices
l'administration se fonde sur une
interprétation juridique des textes et
je pense qu'elle les utilise des arts et
des arguments qui sont contestables et
nous allons les contester devant les
juridictions compétentes dans les
prochains jours le puy du fou en effet
30 jours pour manifester son désaccord
après ce sera de la compétence du
tribunal administratif de poitiers
toute la question est aujourd'hui de
savoir pourquoi l'administration a
changé d'avis et considère l'association
comme une entreprise de spectacle parce
qu'elle rémunère des palefreniers et des
secrétaires et ne remplit pas ainsi les
conditions exonératoire parce que les
prix d'entrée sont ceux du marché
mais quelle est la référence la
cinéscénie n'est pas un son et lumières
traditionnelles c'est inacceptable
rétorque que les responsables c'est
purement et simplement un impôt sur le
bénévolat et sur la générosité puisque
en disant 6 millions ont été distribués
à des associations humanitaires sans
distinction de quoi freiner la bonne
volonté des quelques 2050 puyfolais je
suis assez serein car le puits fowler
ont vu d'autres et ne serait-ce qu des
difficultés qui se sont amassés au fil
des années mais je pense que demain nous
avons suffisamment de forces pour
renverser la vapeur et pour montrer aux
yeux du public
ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
maintenant n'a encore une fois rien dire
reprochable et que malgré
les comment les attaques dont nous
sommes l'objet aujourd'hui ne seront ne
feront que renforcer l'image de marque
du puy du fou en général près de deux
millions 900 mille personnes auront vu
depuis 14 ans le spectacle du puy du fou
et la version 91 s'achève tout juste que
l'heure est déjà là aussi au bilan et
aux perspectives
monique jocelyn la 14e année du puy du
fou vient de se terminer en beauté
il s'agit d'une année record avec 214
1105 visiteurs pour le grand parcours et
316 1600 spectateurs pour le spectacle
du soir
de quoi nourrir de grandes ambitions
pour l'année qui vient où sont prévus
d'importantes nouveautés à commencer par
la construction d'une galerie
souterraine de 100 mètres de long où
seront évoqués les scènes historiques
les plus marquantes des guerres de
vendée
le spectacle du soir verra sa mise en
scène modifier de façon importante avec
des effets techniques toujours nouveaux
dont un jeu de laser sur la fin du
spectacle qui viendra illuminer le
célèbre lac
ces renouvellements du spectacle sont
destinés tant aux spectateurs qu'aux
puis follet dont il faut préserver
l'enthousiasmé la fraîcheur face à un
spectacle toujours en évolution
quand on sait que le puy du fou est le
lieu le plus visité de france
après versailles et chambord on comprend
qu'ils tiennent à garder son rang
ce sont plus de 200 à 1000 visiteurs qui
sont attendus cette année pour la visite
dans ce grand parcours au coeur duquel
se situe sa village de fatick les
époques xviiie siècle des artisans
cautionnait la portée du survivant à ses
tableaux historiques étape vers le
culturel le plus fréquenté de france
après versailles et chambord grand
parcours du puy du fou est devenu de
réputation nationale et c'est le premier
grand parc national même européen pour
sa dimension historique et puis sa
dimension écologique pour retenir
l'attention du public il faut chaque
année proposer de nouvelles attractive
nouveauté cette reconstitution d'une
tanière de luz où on leur met en
paillers ce conservatoire d'animaux
sauvages modèle réduit la memorial des
guerres de vendée dramatiser s'il en
était besoin par le régulière de verdi
et un carillon à automates
le grand parcours est tout jeune le
grand parcours n'a que 3 ans et
progressivement il faut l'amener à une
dimension qui soit une dimension
internationale
il faut densifier toutes les attractions
une présentant tous les jours au public
[Musique]
cette jeune et talentueuse double roue
des attractions du tarp humour elle
appuie son métier dans tous les bons
coups
cet actif
[Musique]
après le vendée globe le tour de france
décidément la vendée n'en finit pas de
parler d'elle cérémonie d'ouverture du
tour de france hier soir sur le site du
puy du fou les formations engagées ont
été présentés devant un nombreux public
[Musique]
fast dans le bocage pour cette épreuve
devenue désormais institutions lavande
et son président nous ont fait un tour à
leurs façons ne manquait pas un bouton
de guêtre 800 bénévoles du spectacle pas
un mollet même des plus prestigieux
comme celui d'eddy merckx le roi de la
vendée présenter la petite reine en
grand apparat
on est très heureux très fier parce que
ce soir la grande aventure du puy-du-fou
rencontre la grande aventure du tour de
france est formidable pour nous moyens
lourds et france2 moyens légers france 3
les 18 équipes du tour de france
cycliste ont salué comme de vrais romain
les 15000 spectateurs du cirque depuis
de presque tout paris télévisuelle était
je suis très heureux et très fier et
c'est vrai que j'aime le cyclisme j'ai
fait du vélo dans ma vie j'en fais
encore maintenant je dirais que celle ce
support que je pratique non pas en
compétition j'ai passé l'âge mais parce
que je sais que c'est un sport complet
et je sais que le tour de france aussi
quelque chose qui réunit tous nos
compatriotes
je suis très heureux que france 3 nantes
soit présent subtil mélange des genres
muscles histoire et traditions un
spectacle superbe est bien rodé un
impact médiatique certain toute la
presse sportive en a parlé ou en parlera
est au paradis des libres penseurs le
meilleur d'entre tous les journalistes
le vélo monsieur jadis où antoine
blondin a dû sourire dans sa barre
[Applaudissements]
vingt ans c'est l'âge de la jeunesse et
déjà 5 millions de spectateurs 20 ans
ces jeunes et ces vieux l'aventuré a
commencé en 1977 ou en l'an mil on ne
sait plus l'an mil qui du reste est le
nouveau spectacle de cet homme
l'histoire du puy du fou a été une à une
aventure depuis 1978
le puy du fou était méconnu il est
maintenant reconnue et en même temps il
est en plein développement tournée vers
l'avenir en 1900 sont 18 c'était un pari
fou avec un scénario de philippe de
villiers
une population qui s'est progressivement
enrôlé dans le cadre de ce scénario
et puis un succès inouï dès la première
année qui ne s'est jamais démenti depuis
la première du spectacle est un succès
la suite c'est la progression chaque
année des spectateurs cette année sans
doute sept cent mille visiteurs au grand
parcours 350 mille spectateurs à la
cinéscénie et une croissance qui devrait
avoisiner les 25% le tas de broussailles
d'il y a 20 ans est devenue un parc
ultra moderne sans perdre de son
authenticité mais qui finance
bien entendu le puy du fou vit
uniquement de la fréquentation du
million de personnes qui y viennent
chaque année c'est maintenant plus de
110 millions de chiffre d'affaires 600
emplois pendant l'été et puis un bassin
autour de du puy du fou de l'ordre de
1500 personnes puisque nous faisons
travailler essentiellement les personnes
autour du puy du fou lors du fort de
l'an mil à la cité médiévale jusqu'au
castel du puy du fou
c'est d'un château l'autre que
s'envolent depuis 20 ans cette ferry
pour une autre fois
[Musique]
c'est un petit village tranquille au
milieu des collines douces ans habitant
une épicerie une boulangerie et des
lotissements tout neuf
tranquille enfin pas pour tout le monde
gellé truche et on s'active
flora et andrée sont à 7 km du puy du
fou et leur gîte ne désemplit pas au
niveau clientèle mardi c'est notre qu'au
motif d'appel
quand le puy du fou et où r on a on est
plein presque tout le temps et ont
refusé parce qu'on a plus place chez
paul bégin ses saucissons pâtés et
andouillettes habituellement l'atelier
emploie 25 personnes
l'été c'est aussi le moment fort de
l'année nous fournissons la restauration
du puy du fou
y compris bien sûr l'auberge avec le
restaurant gastronomique
c'est pendant cinq mois six à sept
emplois une retombée également un direct
avec tous les magasins la restauration
dont alan tout qui viennent
s'approvisionner chez nous ça représente
peut-être 10% de notre chiffre
d'affaires c'est vraiment important il y
a quelques années le camping municipal
belgique
aujourd'hui il affiche complet 90 % de
sa clientèle via du puy du fou et le
camping envisage de se développer en a
chance d'être situé à quelques minutes à
quelques kilomètres du puy du fou est
depuis une quinzaine d'années voire un
petit peu plus et bien la fréquentation
du camping suit celle de du
développement du fils du fou on peut
dire aussi en élargissant un petit
peuple la commune de saint malo du bois
qui comprend 200 habitants a été boostée
aussi par cette proximité là
effectivement grâce au puy du fou
ça maintient à la fois un tissu
économique touristique qui est
nécessaire pour les petites communes
comme
comme la nôtre le point faible et
l'hébergement
conséquence cholet angers et nantes
profite de l'occasion mais au delà des
collines avoisinantes c'est toute la
région qui est concerné la vendée attire
par le littoral mais aujourd'hui on a
des visiteurs qui viennent
spécifiquement pour le puy du fou et qui
ne vont pas forcément aller sur la côte
d'ailleurs mais qui vont faire d'autres
visites culturelles notamment dans le
maroc allait quelque chose c'est 750
saisonniers 70 permanents 1500 emplois
7000 bénévoles mais n'allez surtout pas
prononcer
entreprise ici on évoque plutôt l'esprit
un premier ministre buvant de champagne
au goulot l'ambiance est plus que
festive pour souffler les bougies du 25e
anniversaire du puy du fou
jean pierre raffarin était arrivé à 17
heures sur place invité par philippe de
villiers s'est tout autant le premier
ministre que le voisin de poitou
charentes qui est venu saluer la
réussite du grand parc
le quatrième en france en nombre
d'entrées avec plus d'un million de
visiteurs l'an dernier
nous mesurons bien la chance qu'a eue le
plus du fou de pouvoir prendre place
dans l'agenda le plus chargé de l'homme
le plus sollicité de la france estivale
je suis un puits folle et de conviction
mais aussi mon cher philippe je suis un
puits forés d'admiration cette visite
privée mais fastueuse rendait hommage
aussi aux 2500 puis foley ces bénévoles
vendéen de la france d'en bas qui depuis
deux générations maintenant participent
telle aventure
déjà il ya beaucoup plus que les drames
et je crois que là ça renforce encore
plus marqués erreur leur plaisir d'être
sifflé sens bien j'ai vu le puy du fou
se développer s'agrandir devenir ce
qu'il est c'est à dire maintenant
mondialement connu avec une
fréquentation pratiquement plus forte
quotidiennement que le disneyland c'est
quand même appréciable et ça c'est parti
de rien aucune folie d'une idée de
philippe que tout le monde à se trouver
saugrenue ans peut-il personne n'a cru
et qui est devenu aujourd'hui 25 ans
après le puy du fou
l'événement avait été longuement
préparée et surveillée par les services
de sécurité depuis le 14 juillet on est
encore plus méfiants mais ce surcroît de
précaution n'a pas gâché la fête
[Musique]